the worst thing about ng Rx is the sheer
amount of code that it takes to build
anything but you're rewarded for that
extra effort with a global data store
that's easy to test and debug and cool
things like the Redux dev tools here on
the right to address the amount of
boilerplate code in ng rx they recently
released a new package called entity it
provides a standardized way to manage
collections of objects and perform basic
credence on them in this episode I'm
going to use entity to build this basic
Pizza ordering app here on the left and
I'm also going to show you how to build
feature modules with ng Rx if you're new
to my channel make sure to subscribe and
if you're new to ng Rx check out my
previous QuickStart tutorial which is a
much easier introduction into these
concepts I am starting out with a brand
new angular app called ng rx pizza so
will CD into that directory and then
install store and entity from there I
create a new module called pizza this
will be our feature module then I'm
going to add a single component to it
we'll just call that component pizza
order then we'll open the module up and
import the store module then I'm
importing a reducer that has not yet
been created but we're going to get into
that a little bit later we're going to
add the store module to the import
section and then call for feature with
the name of our reducer and the reducer
itself
this approach is trivial here because we
only have one feature but when you have
multiple features this will help keep
your code much more organized so the
next step is to create a directory
called reducers in the app directory and
then inside that create a file called
index is then we'll import action
reducer map and our pizza reducer and
then we'll export all of our reducers as
a single constant in this example we
only have one but you can imagine how
much more convenient this would be if
you had 10 different reducers to manage
at this point we're ready to jump over
to the app module then import the store
module as well as optionally the dev
tools module and then we're going to
import our pizza module that we just
created as well as the reducers index
file that we just created now we can
just import the store module for route
and pass it the reducers object then we
can go ahead and add dev tools here and
we'll also add our
to module 2 imports that's it for our
feature module now we can get into
entity to start building an actual
[ __ ] I'm going to start by building a
pizza reducer ts file inside the pizza
directory and then I'm importing actions
here which we haven't created yet but
we'll do that in the next step and a few
other ng rx parts that we'll see in use
here in just a second the first thing
we'll do is create a basic interface
that defines how our data is going to
look the pizza interface is only going
to have an ID and a size so extremely
simple here then we use this interface
to create an entity adapter which is
going to format the data in a specific
way as well as provide access to a
number of different helpers for
performing crud operations the next step
is to make sure our Pizza interface is
part of the main app state we do that by
extending the state interface with the
entity state interface type to our pizza
interface that sounded extremely
confusing so let's take a closer look at
what the entity state really is by
creating a plain JavaScript object out
of it the entity state is just an
interface that gives our data a
consistent structure first we have an
array of IDs and this makes it possible
to order all of our entities then
entities is an object where each key and
that object corresponds to an ID in the
array this structure means you can keep
track of order based on the index in the
array or you can just grab a single
object by calling the key and the
entities object so we're just going to
use this default object as our initial
state to do that we define a new
variable called initial state and then
on the adapter we call get initial state
and finally pass it the default data
that we want to set before we actually
create the reducer function I'm going to
create some actions to use in that
reducer if you're already familiar with
ng rx the actions work in exactly the
same way as they do with the normal
library as they do an entity let's start
by creating three simple actions create
update and delete for each of these will
create its own custom class and that
class will have a data payload that
needs to be formatted in a certain way
it's pretty intuitive the data is
defined in the constructor and for a
create operation we just want to pass it
data that represents that object so in
this case it would just be a pizza
object that adheres to our Pizza
interphase the update action is a little
more interesting we want to change an
existing object without affecting all of
its other already defined properties so
to do that we'll go ahead and pass the
constructor an ID and then we'll also
pass it some data but only do a partial
on the pizza interface so this allows us
to update single properties on an object
with that interface and finally to
delete an object we can just pass in an
ID to look it up in the store and we'll
finish it off by exporting all these
actions as a single type I realize this
has been super fast but remember you can
get all of the source code at angular
firebase.com or github now we're ready
to go back and finish up the reducer
function you might be used to using the
spread syntax or object to sign in your
reducer functions but now we're actually
going to use the entity adapters instead
just like any other reducer will pass at
the previous state as well as the
corresponding action and then we'll set
up the switch statement and start
updating our state keep in mind that
entity provides a whole bunch of other
adapter methods beyond the ones that I
showed you here to add a single object
to the store we just use the add one
method and then pass that object payload
from the action then we pass the
previous state as a second argument from
there we can move on to update and it's
going to use the update 1 method this
one needs the object ID as well as the
data that we want to update at this
point you're probably noticing how the
action payloads correspond to the
required arguments for these adapter
methods
lastly we'll set up delete and this one
is handled by the remove 1 adapter
method that takes care of the reducer
now we need to set up some selectors so
we can actually retrieve data from the
store the cool thing about entity is it
has a whole bunch of default ways for
retrieving data for example we could get
an array of IDs or just the entities or
all the data together first we need to
create a feature selector which I'm
going to call get pizza state then we
can export the default selectors then
set them equal to the pizza adapter get
selectors method with get pizza state as
an argument
we'll be able to use these when we call
store select to get the data in a
predefined format let's head over to the
pizza order component to see this in
action I'm going to import the actions
as well as the reducer but I'm going to
call the reducer from Pizza this is just
a convention that is in the example app
for NG rx first I set up a variable for
the actual observable pizzas that will
loop over in the HTML and then when I
inject the store in the constructor I
add the pizza state to it to get the
actual pizzas observable I'm going to
call store select and then from pizza
with the selector that we want which in
this case we'll just do select all that
will get the data from the store now
we're just going to set up a few event
handlers here to trigger the various
actions for the create action I'm just
gonna create some dummy data here and
give it a pseudo-random ID here by just
calling some random milliseconds from
the JavaScript data object but that's
not something you want to do in a real
app normally you would have that ID
coming from a database or some other
mechanism but for now we'll use this
data to update the store by calling
dispatch with an instance of the create
action all of the other buttons will
work in exactly the same way we just
take the data from the HTML and then
send it via the corresponding action we
finally made it down to the HTML so I'm
declaring that pizza order component in
the app component and then I'll switch
back to our pizza order component HTML
and first we'll set up an ng for loop
here with the async pipe to loop over
our observable then right below that I
set up a button to create a new pizza
which should update the list that we're
looking at in the front-end for each
individual pizza inside the loop I'm
just going to display some basic data
and then I'll set up individual buttons
to run the update action so we're gonna
say if the pizza size is small and the
user clicks the button we're going to
pass the pizza ID as well as large so
that I'll upgrade their pizza to a large
size and then we'll do the exact
opposite here if the pizza is large then
we'll downgrade it to a small size for
delete we can do the exact same thing
but we only need to pass it the ID
if we first load the app you can see we
get the default pizza here which if you
remember had an ID of one two three and
then we can upgrade it or downgrade it
or delete it then if we pull up Redux
step tools we can get a better idea of
what our state tree looks like every
time we click create pizza you can see
we get a new entity added to our state
tree here overall I'd say I'm pretty
impressed with this new addition to ng
rx it can definitely provide more
consistency to the way you deal with
credence throughout the app if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe
and if you want to take your ng rx app
to the next level consider becoming a
pro subscriber at angular firebase comm
you'll get access to one on one project
support as well as a whole bunch of
exclusive content
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]